في الوقت القصير الذي قضيناه هنا،
تم الاستيلاء على هذه الحزمة من الفنتانيل في
البريد، وفي هذا الظرف الآن
قيد التحقيق الفيدرالي، وتم اكتشاف
العقار القاتل بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي،
وقيمته في السوق حوالي 100000 دولار من
الفنتيل، كل قطعة بريد، كل طرد
يدخل إلى  يتم فحص الولايات المتحدة من قبل
مكتب الجمارك وحماية الحدود في الوقت الحالي، ويتم ذلك بواسطة الأشعة السينية حيث
يحدق الضباط في الصور المعروضة على
شاشتهم، وإذا اشتبهوا فيهم،
يقومون بفتح الطرد لتحديد
ما إذا كان هناك تهديد بالداخل ولكن يمكن أن
يحدث ثورة في الطريقة التي
تعمل بها الجمارك وحماية الحدود الأمريكية.  معركة ضد
المهربين، نحن هنا بالقرب من مطار لوس أنجلوس
الدولي في منشأة
تعالج أكثر من 240 مليون طرد
كل عام، حيث يقوم الضباط بمصادرة
العديد من العناصر بما في ذلك
البضائع المقلدة والأطعمة غير القانونية بالإضافة إلى
سلائف مخدر الشمر القاتل الآن
من أجل المساعدة في إيقاف الشمر الأمريكي.
يعتمد ضباط الأوبئة الآن على
الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل هذا النظام، حيث
يتم إرسال حزمة من خلال هذا
النظام الرئيسي المسمى idss وهذا مشابه
لما قد تجده في المستشفى أو في
المطار يتم التقاط صورة ثلاثية الأبعاد ثم
إرسالها إلى ما يسمى الطالب هذا
هو الذكاء الاصطناعي لنظام هالو الذي
يعمل على عكس
التقنيات القديمة مثل الأشعة السينية، حيث
يتعلم
هذا النظام ويعلم نفسه باستمرار. تتمثل مهمة نظام الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا، وهو
جزء من برنامج تجريبي لهيئة الجمارك وحماية الحدود، في
تحديد الأنماط التي يقوم بها المهربون بإخفاء
الفنتانيل لتجنب
اكتشافهم  في نهاية
العملية برمتها، سيحصل النظام على درجة
بعد مسح 10000 صورة،
وسيبحث الضابط لتحديد مدى جودة أداء
النظام فعليًا لتحديد ما إذا كان
هذا هو نوع الآلة التي قد ترغب إدارة الجمارك وحماية الحدود في
طرحها في
منشآتها المتعددة عبر  تخيل الأمة كل
المعلومات التي تأتي إلى
ضباطنا ووكلائنا، إنهم الأفضل في
العالم فيما يفعلونه ولكنهم بحاجة إلى
المساعدة في استخلاص تلك المعلومات حتى
تتمكن من اتخاذ قرار مستنير،
هناك شيء ما يحدث هنا، شيء
غير صحيح ولكن هناك شيء آخر
منتج ثانوي مهم لهذه
التكنولوجيا المتطورة إذا تمكنت كضابط من النظر
إلى نوع ما من الأجهزة وأقول إنك تعرف
ما هو الإنذار الأحمر الكبير، نعم،
فيمكنني بالفعل اتباع
البروتوكولات المناسبة والعزل وإخطار
الأشخاص المناسبين ثم الاعتناء به دون
الحصول على  قريب جدًا وأعرض نفسي أو
الآخرين للخطر، يتم استخدام هذا البرنامج التجريبي حاليًا
للشحنات التي تصل جوًا إلى مطار لوس أنجلوس الدولي
وتأمل إدارة الجمارك وحماية الحدود في توسيع استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي ليشمل
نقاط دخول مهمة أخرى إلى
الولايات المتحدة مثل ميناء لوس
أنجلوس، وهو أكثر الموانئ ازدحامًا في العالم.  الأمة
وفي مجلس الإدارة،
نقطة منشأ رئيسية
لدخول الفنتانيل إلى سوق المخدرات الأمريكية، مما أسفر عن مقتل
الآلاف، سؤال يلوح في الأفق مع
عصابات المخدرات الممولة جيدًا والمعروفة بتبني
تكنولوجيا متقدمة خاصة بها، إلى
متى سيوفر لنا الذكاء الاصطناعي للسلطات
ميزة متطورة للبقاء في المقدمة  من
التهديد